these tuxedoed wobblers our emperor
penguins you may not know it but these
semi-aquatic birds are some of the most
dedicated parents in the animal kingdom
I mean would you be willing to do what
they do spend 65 days
huddled here in this penguin pack in
temperatures that can drop to a hundred
and twelve degrees below zero with winds
of 50 miles an hour even Green Bay
Packer football fans don't have it this
bad fortunately these big birds have
evolved dense feathers and a thick layer
of body fat the remarkable thing is the
one who incubates the egg in a brood
pouch is dad meanwhile mom goes off to
sea looking for food
even after the baby is hatched it's dad
who keeps the baby in the brood pouch
good thing too just two minutes in the
elements and the chick would be a goner
once mom comes back she and dad take
turns heading out for more food since
they aren't mammals they can't feed
their babies with milk instead they have
to make long often arduous treks to
fishing holes where they can be faced
with huge hungry up to thirteen hundred
pound weapon seals
once the coast is clear of predators
the Penguins dive deep and look up to
find fish swimming just under the ice
they're impressive predators and equally
impressive at evading predators then
back at the rook the parent finds its
own shape by voice-recognition parent
calls
and baby answers once they're reunited
baby gets to chow down on regurgitated
fish as the baby grows up mom and dad
eventually hunt for its nourishment
together
so remember that huge seemingly
anonymous group of emperor penguins how
groups like that are made up of
committed parents working in tandem
great parents lucky kid